taking something janky taking something
janky and making it beautiful yeah kind
of like we do with in-depth videos yeah
eighty percent awesome twenty percent
change eighty percent awesome twenty
percent change kind of like we do with
intent
so what happened here buddy
i'm just trying to heat up a little
lunch
and uh you're trying to cool down the
office i swung it shut it wasn't shut so
i came back over to shut it and when i
put my hand on it
so this thing came out real quick what
happened to the butt oh
missing a boat yeah your bolt missing
i think there's no bolts there where'd
it go
oh wait
there's a bolt it
the bolt went up into the door
how does that [ __ ] happen
need your help you see it you see how
there's a bolt right here this thing i
mean yeah it's not a bull but yeah it's
supposed to be down here but it got
pushed up into the door oh did it that's
can you uh help fix this you can't
these are gonna be chainmail this is
gonna be chainmail i gotta i gotta kind
of cut off the top of it though
you take a sweat if you don't want to
use real chain mail because you don't
know an armorer or you don't want to
spend a thousand dollars and you don't
want to put like 80 pounds of metal on
your body for all this you
you buy a really thick sweater like this
that has really thick knit you cut it up
and you paint it from a distance it
looks like chainmail they even did this
in like robin hood the movie and lord of
the rings and vikings and vikings yeah
they do this all the time it's gonna dry
brush it something like that yeah sweet
all right what would you say
is the biggest problem you've
encountered so far
this guy the biggest problem i've found
so far is finding a band jacket that's
not coming from china dude this is
perfect for peter leather vest
peter the farmers farmer that's peter
look i feel like a poo
actually you're ready for west world
yeah
wear that to a bar in silver lake all
your weight is still on his desk by the
way there you go thank you you're good
of course it is
you're good you're good there
i'm just gonna say it this video is
brought to you by squarespace whether
you need a domain website or online
store
use squarespace to make your next move
remember squarespace is flexible for any
kind of website designers musicians
photographers online stores if you've
got a job they've got a square space for
you
[Music]
and don't worry if you get lost in your
squarespace they have award-winning
customer service 24 7.
squarespace has beautiful award-winning
templates for your squarespace just like
my tree here
if you don't believe me go to
squarespace anyway if you guys are
looking to make your own squarespace
start your free trial today by going to
squarespace.com salmonico or use the
promo code samoniko to get 10 off your
first purchase
you're welcome
how do you propose pulling that pin out
you're the engineer that's what i'm
saying you went to school for this
that's one no
yes but you can't just like you have to
take the door apart to get to it then i
challenge you
how does an engineer fix the door
that's the first step to figuring out a
solution is figuring out what the
problem really is first things first the
pin that keeps it hinged here somehow
got pushed up into the door in the
meantime this is just pouring out cold
air that was the my lunch is okay though
right
i don't want to strip it but it actually
looks like a screwable thing
all right super sick unboxing
with the knife that my mother gave me my
mother's knife leather pants dude are
these other pants yes yes they are
damn son
damn i think he's gonna fit into these
he told you he's a 32 32 those are 32's
better fitting them maybe we should give
him to him
over the weekend yeah and let him like
sit in them on a couch and like spray
himself with water
oh my god that is threaded it is a bolt
this straight up is a bolt
it's upside down
i'm aware of that
oh
oh hey look at that this whole sleeve
is inserted here the bolt is screwed
into
the sleeve
there's no entrance on the other side no
it's totally plastic the only piece
it's spinning
see the piece came out
there's gotta be a nut somewhere unless
it came off a while ago and only just
now actually finally came apart
so if a nut did come off it's still
right here it's around people
oh god just gotta sliver my fingernail
i want my sandwich there you go
you need your hand yeah
lunchtime
what happens here
boots
ladylight oh but there's more oh
these look like ladylights pants
yeah
this lady likes a jacket
this is like basically just like a biker
chick that
that yields or that wields magic magic
and then i'm gonna make a little
pauldron for her on one side oh sweet
yeah this works great what is what is
that that should be a new thing is this
me or
little skull or what holy crap i haven't
felt as cool
i don't think ever
don't mess with me i'm an edge lord dude
these are like nick's pants this thing's
all gonna be shot from a drone right
there's no like close-ups of the
characters no that's correct okay so
here's the problem as soon as you start
telling people that you're filming
this is just such a classic scenario
it's a classic scenario where people
wonder why
people do things first without asking
because the moment that you tell someone
that you're filming with a drone this
part of the world
you now need to acquire aviation
insurance workers compensation you need
to be a licensed drone pilot with the
faa you can't just fly a drone 25 feet
in the air and film a patch of grass
which is all we have which is all we're
doing but in order to do that we need to
basically buy another what would that
cost aviation insurance
so you don't fly your drone into someone
else's property it isn't covered under
general aggregate no no no general
aggregates just for walking down the
sidewalk we already have that so here's
the solution if we tell them that we're
gonna fly a drone the easiest thing to
do at this point would be to call flight
test and see if one of their guys can
come down and do it and then we do the
insurance that we need for this
particular thing under there that would
cost about as much as
doing all this but it would happen in
less time because i don't know sam niko
or no they're none of them
they haven't done anything call them
tell them our problem
and ask them if they're interested see
if they can come down they can't come
down uncheck that box be like oh [ __ ]
we're not doing the job filming anything
oh yeah we can just read the regular
films
and then the park is aware that we're
doing it so
right but don't put that in there that's
not something we'd actually do that's
just if someone wanted to that's a
theory that they could use to skirt the
law but we don't do that around here we
do everything by the book that's why
it's quarter digital where everything
almost always works
praise the gin
[Laughter]
also he's gonna plug it all
you really really like a lot that you
can't buy anymore i'm gonna have a guy
sweating for six hours is that cool
this jacket for our main character it's
just his final look dee owns this jacket
it looks great
he's just giving us a hard time
dude he's just giving us a hard time
because it's a van jacket so my chemical
romance yeah it's a total like
you know
and we just nicely asked to borrow it
and he's complaining that somebody's
gonna be sweating in his jacket all
right very it's he's very conflicted
because we hired a guy another guy
there's just our main character in anime
fidget spinners we got to switch things
up
you know
should i just tell them people people
ask what's the
the key motivation to make videos every
other day i'd have to say it's shot and
floyd
can just call it
this really cool jacket that we don't
use anymore that they don't make anymore
that they only made for this album you
know i'm not just going to walk around
all day
sweaty ass dude trust me i know how hot
it's going to be are you recording this
shirt it's a vintage hawaiian shirt from
hawaii
it's friday man it's friday
my dad got it for me in hawaii at a a
real hawaiian shop what what a guy you
know they didn't go to hawaii without me
though so
i'm not mad or anything
there's no nut because yeah this
threaded into that
but it's so thin why would you thread it
like that
stick the door in there
gotta somehow slide it into place maybe
if you weren't so reckless i'm gonna
take this
mounting
thing
off
slip it in the top
yeah pretty much i'm holding it up um
yeah
[Music]
all right
[Music]
all right back to the door
i might need someone to help him hold it
okay
there we go
and then yeah
door should be fixed
door should be fixed
[Applause]
[Music]
we fixed it guys
wasn't a long project
got it done
door explodes and halts all productivity
and studio for young filmmakers
company goes bankrupt
food spoils and everyone starves to
death that's the title of the video
we're about
honestly i'd say we're about
70 done but we only have one more day
after today and there's still a lot to
put together
maybe on prop duty today yeah man you
know me i'm everywhere
making some pauldrons yeah
chest armor pauldrons
you know like you do this is a good one
yep
one more day let's go out tomorrow
i don't know depends on when we get done
today yeah foam smithing should be done
today homesmith foam smithing oh my god
it is still there i dare you to try it
it's frankie
mitchell did when he uh carbon fiber guy
that's like four weeks old
[Music]
you